guys I love the first anchorman movie
and I'm looking forward to the second
one through fandango's super ticket you
can see the film two days early as well
as get a copy of Ron Burgundy The Lost
movie as well as a digital HD download
of anchorman 2 check out the link below
to leave your favorite anchorman quote
in the comment section to win two free
tickets from Fandango
you know throughout the entire runtime
of this movie I kept thinking I would
love if Indiana Jones or like the bear
Jew would just come in here and rip
these Nazis to pieces The Book Thief is
based off of an extremely successful
novel it's about a young girl named
Liesl and she's just been adopted and
she's living in World War two Germany so
to find some relief from this horrible
thing that's going on all around her she
starts stealing books while people
everywhere around here are burning books
she figures out a way to steal them
along with the help of her adoptive
father played by Geoffrey Rush they
learned how to read with each other and
then they use these books as a way to
enrich their lives throughout this
terrible terrible time they live in the
book leave is a movie that I was very
interested in because my fiance loves
the book and she told me a few things
about it you know she didn't spoil
anything but she got my interest piqued
I'm kind of a sucker for a good movie
that is able to portray people who find
the best way to live in a horrible time
you know the kind of movie where
everyone around is just suffering but
there's maybe one or two people that try
to make the best of it I kind of like
movies like that if they're done well
and gratefully The Book Thief was I
thought this was a very emotionally
effective movie it's not a perfect movie
it does have its flaws this is a film
that is very heartwarming that is able
to show what it's like to live in an
area like this during this time but at
the same time it also finds a way to
show some humanity which is one of the
best parts about this movie is the fact
that there's this great human core to it
that you can really relate to because
these characters are dealing with the
worst times of their lives and their
daily seeing these horrible atrocities
happen while they're trying to survive
in Germany during World War two and they
find a way to get out of that situation
at least inside their heads and that's
one of the best things about this movie
is the imaginative nature of the
characters particularly the father and
the young daughter watching them teach
each other how to read and shelter a Jew
who has been fleeing from the Nazis and
their relationship that develops between
that man they're sheltering and the
little girl is extremely sweet these two
characters need each other desperately
because the little girl doesn't have her
real parents anymore horrible things are
happening all around her and she doesn't
really have too many people to relate to
except a neighboring boy her new father
and a mother who is immensely strict so
this guy that they start to shelter in
the base
and her develop this great relationship
that I thought was one of the strongest
points of this movie and for the large
majority of this movie I really enjoyed
what I saw it's a beautifully shot movie
the production design is also excellent
like I really bought the location it
really seemed like they were in World
War Two Germany at that time and I loved
that about this movie the look of it is
terrific
Joffre rush brought such a great sense
of fun to this movie because he's sort
of the father who adopts this girl and
you really feel like he's the guy who
understands how she feels he understands
her plight he understands that she's in
a terrible position he is always there
to try to make it fun for her he did
such a great job in this movie also Ben
Netzer plays max the Jew that they are
sheltering in the basement he was also
really good in the movie his character
seemed very realistic his performance
did not feel faked or forced at all the
young girl who plays Liesel was also
great really the acting in the movie all
around is really good and that's one of
the strongest parts of this movie the
acting the look of the film and also
John Williams excellent score the whole
movie I was like why is this music so
good and then during the end credits it
said music by John Williams and I was
like what he rarely ever composes for
anyone other than Spielberg anymore and
I thought that his score as usual was
beautiful if there's one man in
Hollywood who's never disappointed with
anything it's John Williams during the
third act of this movie the movie
unfortunately gets lost in some
melodrama or some of the more serious
and realistic elements of the first two
acts kind of get lost in this weepy oh
woe is me kind of finale that that isn't
bad it's not bad I know it's in the book
there were certain elements of it that
were actually changed from the book from
what I understand I'm trying to say is
that there are parts of this movie that
are very sentimental and sometimes that
can be really good and sometimes that
can be really bad and elements of this
movie do it extremely well
but then there are certain parts of the
film where you're feeling like okay I
get that you're tugging at my
heartstrings but now this just feels
fake so besides some melodramatic
elements towards the end I really
thought The Book Thief was a pretty good
movie I thought it was a very well shot
looking movie as well as acted and I'm
going to give it a B so guys what is
your favorite movie that takes place
during world war ii i know there's a lot
of options but can you pick just one
as always guys thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck
nice
[Music]